well we can get more on the situation on
the ground in ukraine joining me in the
studio now is justin crump chief
executive of sibiline military expert
and veteran british army tank commander
good to have you with us it's always
good to have your expertise here now
talk us through uh what has been
happening overnight reports of some
russian assaults taking place uh in some
areas some in the north of the country
chernohit there
how does that fit in to the wider
strategic goals of the russian military
what you're seeing with these overnight
strikes uh carried out by precision
weapons mostly cruise missiles either
fire from the black sea or from russian
uh aircraft
is an attempt to disrupt the flow of
materials around the country for ukraine
both to affect civilian resilience uh so
the infrastructure of ukraine uh but
also mainly to stop nato weapons
supplies from getting into the country
and that's a big focus for russia so
they've been attacking diesel fuel
railway lines warehouses for food
that's a vulnerability for ukraine and
also particularly anywhere they think
the military equipment is being stored
and that campaign has continued night
after night with obvious risks to
civilians amongst that
also hearing about the counter offensive
coming from ukrainian forces uh just
tell us where that is kicking off on
this map yes if you kind of think of the
whole battle area you see here kind of
going from from north to south you have
cockey
where ukrainian forces have been pushing
in on the flank of the russian offensive
they've achieved good success there and
pushing the russians back towards the
border um but of course russia mainly
focused on the donbass area
and this area here towards zapposia um
and then on the western flank of the
russian side you have kersen which is
the main city the only a blast capital
that russia has managed to capture big
an iconic location for them but ukraine
is also building up forces there and
then finally you have transnistria
moldova odessa and snake island we've
been hearing about snake island of
course from the very early days that
iconic sort of scene of resistance from
ukrainian forces exactly but it has more
than just an iconic significance i think
when we look at the island um its
location the black sea is very strategic
and um ukraine's actually been focused
very heavily on trying to stop russia
from building up almost if you like a
land-borne warship on the island so
russia's been trying to get long-range
surface-to-air missile systems in there
that actually helps them replace the
vessel they lost the moskva by putting
some of these systems in place on the
island so for a very small rock and you
can see the sort of scale of it there
it's become quite important and
ukraine's effectively been able to keep
striking back at the island with its air
forces which has quite disrupted russian
plans in fact they may have lost another
auxiliary vessel today near the island
as well so a lot still going on for
again a very small spec in the ocean but
of great significance in current
conflict yeah okay well we're going to
show our map again of ukraine because i
also would like you to tell us what the
latest situation in the donbass is well
yeah and i think the very interesting
thing about the fighting in donbass at
the moment is the effect of the dom
river itself it's worth waiting for i
know it does come up um
it's uh the don the actual donetsk river
itself is actually one of the key
features of the battlefield at the
moment it runs pretty much along the
northern edge of ukrainian positions
both forces are on either side of the
river but russia's working very hard to
cross it and i think we have some
footage
as well of
an unsuccessful russian river crossing
that's been taking place in this area
now they tried to cross the river again
and again they did this earlier in the
war around disem and they did eventually
succeed but they kept trying with these
pontoon bridges to cross the river um
it's a very difficult operation in war
especially modern war where you can't
hide from satellites even commercial
satellite imagery let alone drones
and russia certainly on this particular
crossing uh lost around 70 or 80
vehicles uh which is a lot i mean that's
effectively one entire battalion
tactical group of vehicles that were
stranded on the wrong side of the river
when the bridges were destroyed behind
them how wide is the river
um it varies significantly uh i think
we've actually got a picture of this
part uh where actually it comes up but
you're looking at around at least 20
meters so it's it's too big and too deep
to forward easily and of course it's
still muddy in parts this area the banks
aren't great to cross and russian uh
forces only have so many locations they
can pick across the river so it does
make that predictable and that seems to
be why
this
particular operation failed quite
spectacularly but that was a few days
ago russian troops do appear to be on
the far bank of the river now and it all
points towards cutting off several
donetsk at the very eastern end of the
ukrainian salient in donbass so we
expect a lot more fighting around there
in the next few days